Our sense of smell plays a huge role in our
sense of taste; the sensation of flavour is
actually a combination of both these senses.
But there's also a link between our sense
of smell and obesity, according to a new study.
It’s a lot more complicated than eating
more when food smells amazing.
Turns out savouring the aroma of your food
could be adding inches to your waistline.
The research was done using mice, not humans,
but it still applies to us.
Using gene therapy, the team temporarily destroyed
olfactory neurons in the noses of adult mice,
leaving them without a sense of smell.
Another group of mice was left with their
sense of smell intact.
The two groups were then fed the same high-fat
diet.
The mice without a sense of smell stayed trim,
gaining no more than 10 percent of their body
weight.
Some heavier mice actually lost weight with
their sense of smell gone.
And it was all fat loss — there was no effect
on the mass of their muscles, bone density,
or organs.
The mice whose sense of smell was left intact,
on the other hand, just about doubled in size.
This US-based team compared notes with another
team in Germany researching with supersmellers
— mice with acute olfactory nerves.
These mice gained even more weight on a standard
diet than normal mice.
The researchers found the smell-deficient
mice regulated their sympathetic nervous system
to burn more calories.
They were able to turn their subcutaneous
fat storage cells into brown fat cells, the
good ones that burn fatty acids to produce
heat.
Some actually turned almost all their subcutaneous
fat into brown fat, making them super lean.
The fat mice among the smell-less group also
regained normal glucose tolerance, taking
them back from the precipice of diabetes.
The negative effect was an increase of noradrenaline,
a stress hormone whose release is also tied
to the sympathetic nervous system.
In humans, too much of this hormone can lead
to heart attacks.
Odor and olfactory sensations, it turns out,
do more than make food taste better.
At least, in mice.
Smell mechanisms affect the way the body deals
with calories.
Weight gain is more than high caloric intake,
it’s also about how the body perceives and
deals with the calories.
Without being able to smell it, your body
is more likely to burn the calories than store
them, suggesting a firm link between the olfactory
system and the regions in the brain that control
metabolism.
It’s also possible that the lack of being
able to smell tricks the body into thinking
it’s not hungry so fat stored while hunting
for food is burned as soon as the body is
fed.
The specifics of the neural circuits involved
with this aren’t well known just yet, but
the link is there for further study.
Again, this result comes from a trial done
with mice in a lab, but it’s also one of
the first really in-depth studies into how
we can manipulate olfactory inputs and brain
circuitry to affect energy balance, and there
will certainly be more.
If scientists find a way to replicate this
result in humans and develop a drug that blocks
the metabolic circuitry without damaging the
sense of smell, it could be a game changer
in the fight against rising obesity rates.
Special thanks to our sponsor, Domain dot
com.
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 15% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
Speaking of appetizing, our early ancestors
resorted to cannibalism.
Can’t imagine that’d smell too good…
we’ve got a video about that right here.
Would you sacrifice your sense of smell to
shed a few pounds?
Let us know in the comments, give this video
a like, and be sure to subscribe so you never
miss an episode of Seeker.